the unitary method is as the name
suggests it's a way of doing something
similar to the kinds of questions you
were looking at yesterday but again it's
another strategy right it's a little bit
like if you were you know becoming a
handyman or a plumber or a a carpet
differencing like that you always want
to have lots and lots of methods
techniques strategies up your sleeve so
that you can depending on the problem
that's in front of you you can pick the
most effective way right so this is a
really kind of way of doing it the
unitary method here's an example
question that is a great candidate for
the unitary method you don't have to use
the unitary method but it's really good
15 percent of an amount and the whole
point of it saying an amount is I don't
know what it is okay is $75 okay the
question that might get pose to you is
well what was the amount what was that
entire amount what did you actually
start with before you took fifteen
percent and got a result okay now we
looked at a question like this yesterday
we introduced some algebra in order to
solve it and that was great that was
fine but you don't have to appeal to
eligible let's think about how this is
gonna work um use it right it just means
one just like when you plant new dirt or
with things that United put into one to
try so this is all about trying to
express the units of the question right
so we're talking about percentages
percentages so 15 percent is that then I
should be able to use this information
to work out one percent right like if I
know what 15 percent is it shouldn't be
that hard to work out what just one
percentage because that's the unit I'm
interested right in fact it's well it's
15 percent divided by 15 that's what one
percent is right it's like easy 15
percent just chop it into a whole bunch
of chunks so that each one is 1% in size
yes
they give you one percent of them yes
great question right so at the moment I
haven't said anything dramatic I've just
said 15 by 15 is one it's like you know
well done do you want medal okay no not
yet I'm going to bring this in contact
with this question take a signal talk so
50% in this particular question is $75
so I'm going to do what we call a
substitution right I'm going to swap out
I'm gonna change replace this 15% with
$75 because that's what it is in this
case so it's 75 dollars over 50 you see
what I've done I just had 50% before I'm
just replacing it just swapping $75
divided by 50 if you're really good with
your times tables it's good to go show
me 15 30 45 60 75 right so I can fit
five dollars out of that right that's
how many watts I get out so what's it
all about Hold'em out is gonna be five
dollars but once you've got one it's
super easy to get to the whole amount
because what is the whole amount
what percentage it's a it's a hundred
percent right a hundred out of a hundred
so if one percent is this that all I
have to do is multiply both sides by a
hundred you see that and that'll land me
with on the left hand side a hundred
percent 1 times 100 and over here
five dollars 100 but 100 of them five
hundred dollars done does that make
sense now we can we can test this out to
see if this answer actually makes sense
without question right
suppose I rephrase the question
I said 15% and I think the amounts 500
right so if I said I can't have a
different question this is the question
you used to get it yesterday 15%
all and then they tell you an amount and
then you have to answer how would you
answer that question we looked at a
couple of methods yesterday for doing
this you want to give me suggestion what
could I do you can use your calculator
for this yeah tonight 50 over 100 great
idea that's 15% and then the all is
multiplication
yeah that's exactly right you can cancel
the hundred here and you're going to get
$75 which is what we started with isn't
it okay so it checks out this method
that we've gone through to get to 1% and
that's a nice easy path to a hundred
percent that's what's called the unitary
method okay